ils ont choisi le meilleur braquet pour
leur ascension économique avec 20% de
croissance cette année all tricks signe
encore de bons résultats sur sa
plateforme de e-commerce et dans ses
trois magasins cinquante mille produits
sont proposés à la vente
c'est le cas de l'établissement à
coignières ouvert depuis 2015 dans une
offre qui s'étoffe d'année en année une
clientèle qui devient de plus en plus
exigeante sur les tout derniers produits
à nous on arrive à avoir beaucoup de
choix
on a notamment une grosse grosse
progression sur les ventes de vélos
électriques
la réussite du magasin il ya le choix il
ya la technicité et donc du coup tout le
conseil qu'on peut apporter aux gens les
gens en fait tu voyais beaucoup de
produits sur notre site
et du coup se dirige vers la boutique
pour avoir des conseils on a vraiment
tous types de personnes on a vraiment de
je tairai la ménagère de plus de 50 ans
qui veut se remettre au sport et du coup
qui s'achète un vélo et rik deville aux
passionnés compétiteurs et du coup on a
une grosse aussi clientèle de club de
vélo de toute la région
tall tricks une start up créée en 2008
elle emploie plus de 150 collaborateurs
cette année l'amazone saint quentinois
du vélo a ouvert son troisième magasin à
issy les moulineaux au mois de mai puis
en septembre le géant du sport français
décathlon a racheté hall tricks une
acquisition bénéfique pour les deux
sociétés
aujourd'hui pour des quatre rondes ça
permet justement d'avoir un vrai
spécialiste vélo sur tout type de
produit donc aujourd'hui on n'hésite pas
à rediriger les clients soit d'un côté
soit de l'autre aujourd'hui autre hic
c'est le site leader en france sur la
vente de vélos running out door en ligne
et décathlon est le leader mondial en
magasin donc c'est d'allier nos forces
ont eu sur le magasin pour nous
apprendre à nous développer
henri tel physique et nous aussi de
transmettre notre savoir faire
a décathlon et ensemble c'est de
proposer de meilleurs services aux
consommateurs
2010neuf c'est aussi le renforcement de
la visibilité de la marque
un spot publicitaire à chaque diffusion
des étapes du tour de france sur france
télévisions on a réussi à négocier une
visibilité forte pendant les directs
pendant la reprise transmission sur
france télévisions donc ça nous a
apporté beaucoup de retombées positives
et un sur trois trafic sur le site
pendant la période du mois de juillet
hall tricks bascule déjà vers l'année
2020 avec des nouveaux projets des
nouveaux défis
on ouvre la vente d'occasion de vélos
d'occasion sur notre site internet
depuis quelques semaines c'est en ligne
2020 soit aussi l'international on va
continuer à développer notre présence en
dehors des frontières en se focalisant
sur l'espagne l'italie et l'allemagne
le chiffre d'affaires en 2010 neuf
devrait atteindre les 80 millions
d'euros objectif pour cette entreprise
du e-commerce maintenir le guidon dans
cette direction pour 2020